[Music]
thanks Jessica I so um guess this is the
last round of talks at CSS calm so sad
let's get the party started so we can go
to the party afterwards I want to first
off say a big thanks to the organizers
they put together a beautiful amazing
wonderful event so if you guys could all
give the organizers a round of applause
I owe them all so much for helping me
out so and I'm completely honored to be
up here with all these other great
speakers I do have to give a quick
disclaimer really quick my slides do
feature some like optical illusions and
animations that if you feel like visual
sensitivity I will not be offended if
you need to get up and like go outside
and take a walk because you have to take
please take care of yourself first I'll
try to give you a warning before
something visually animated pops up on
the screen but today we're going to talk
about CSS and art history and all of the
wonderful things that we have in common
as a front-end developer we work in an
industry where our job is to build
things for public consumption and the
thing is is that often like we're given
sets of designs and photographs and text
and we have to put that all together in
order to tell a story on a website and
what better place to look at for
inspiration of visual storytelling than
art history so the object of art is not
to reproduce reality but to create a
reality of the same intensity and
effective storytelling in our
it comes from a long long history of
patterns and symbolism and visual cues
that have been developed over the course
of time and what's interesting is that
today we're kind of in the opposite
situation back in medieval times and in
the Renaissance illiteracy was the
majority of like people weren't as
capable of reading as they are today
obviously and when we work on websites
our job is often to make text available
and readable however we're still working
in a two-dimensional media we are still
working with a screen that has quite a
lot in common with the canvas and with
the frame so during this talk there's
going to be a lot of like little
examples of fun CSS things that I felt
inspired to share with you
this is one of my favorite websites it's
actually in flash but I'm working on
building like CSS JavaScript version of
it but I just wanted to show you this is
animated and moves around a lot
it's a game called first-person Tetris
you can go to first-person Tetris calm I
waste a lot of time playing this so
instead of the pieces rotating the whole
screen rotates and the reason why I'm
showing this to you is because we often
forget that like as long as we look at
the physical world the three
dimensionality of vision seems to offer
no problem until we recall that the
optical input for all of our visual
experience consists of two-dimensional
projections on the retina like this is a
game but it's also a piece of art
because it's a two-dimensional
representation of space that you have a
three-dimensional relationship with see
I've only ever gotten to level 10 so if
you can get past level 10 because it
starts going really fast and then you
get really really dizzy
so like I was saying it's we're dealing
with like a two dimensional world right
on our screens and our screens give us
access to the same things that you have
access to when you're putting together a
painting we have access to space and
lines and light and color and all these
things that come together to make form
which is what we are talking about when
we look at art history is the nature of
form so let's break that down a little
bit more so this is a wonderful Georgia
O'Keeffe quote that I love where she's
talking about what it is to make art the
reason why we elevate art is because art
gives you the chance it gives you a
chance to have an intimate emotional
relationship with something and that
intimate emotional relationship comes
from the arrangement of shapes and lines
and color and all of these things that
are just two-dimensional tools and we
have access to with CSS they all
contribute to expression so starting
back from like way way beginning these
are cave paintings in the South of
France
from 30,000 to 32,000 years ago it's
kind of hard to carbon-date these things
but you can see that there is already an
understanding of form like there's white
and there's dark so there's an
understanding of highlighting and
saturation there's movement the animals
are running across the rock right but
just like early web design before we had
access to like flexbox and CSS grid and
all these really cool things that we
have now just like in art history CSS
was used in basic motifs that were
changed with trends across time so cave
paintings being the earliest and then
maybe you look at greco-roman vase art
and then you look at the motifs of
medieval art they're generally all
sticking to the same motif in the same
way that very very
very early web development stuck to the
same motif but then we have the
Renaissance and the Renaissance was
responsible for basically making us go
from a representational form of art to a
realistic form of art and I believe that
right now we exist in a sort of
Renaissance period of CSS where we have
access to all of these wonderful cool
new tools but we're still doing the job
of tradesmen and craftsmen we're still
dictated to us what it is that we're
communicating through our web
development onto the screen same as how
the artists during the Renaissance were
usually patronized by the Medici in the
family and the families in the countries
all across all across Europe and one of
the greatest contributions of the
Renaissance to art was the concept of
vanishing point so a vanishing point is
a geometrical representation of an
expression of space by locating a point
on the horizon and pulling it into the
foreground you're able to create
three-dimensional objects so before
during medieval and like on Greek vases
you would see a very flat
two-dimensional picture of a person but
now with vanishing points we have the
ability to truly understand space and
here you can see the very famous Last
Supper which is a fresco by Leonardo da
Vinci and here he takes great advantage
of the vanishing point but not only that
there's also hidden messages with this
composition in and of itself the fact
that the vanishing point is centred and
the horizon is centred is a method of
demonstrating symmetry and symmetry
demonstrates perfection because for two
things to be equal on both sides that is
perfection and back in the Renaissance
this was considered godliness
so we derive this expectation
perfection and centering and it's
probably why all of us have to struggle
with vertical center alignment so much
to this day because of this crap here is
a more intense version if after looking
at where the horizon exists and the
vanishing point exists in the last
supper we can kind of take it to the
next level with Rafael in his fresco the
School of Athens which is in the Vatican
the vanishing point itself is actually
between Plato and Aristotle therefore
centering our focus on the conversation
that is happening between the two
characters in the center however there's
also lines of of geometric form that are
happening in the foreground and with the
crossing of the lines we see that this
is like a much more complex version of
what was started in the Renaissance like
this is the the growth of it and you can
do it with CSS this is vanishing points
being executed with prospective origin
and because my slides are all HTML and
CSS I can show you how I did it so all
this right here is how I'm able to
execute the same thing that da Vinci and
Raphael executed in my code
so using vanishing points also gives us
access to depth and in that same sense
that we have access to depth with
vanishing points our screens are like
windows they're showing us what is
within in the same way that a frame
shows you what is within a painting and
this was the big movement that happened
in the Renaissance and kind of defined
art for the next few motifs into the
Baroque period
and the neoclassical period which is
still kind of happening today I love
this piece of art it's cannot pronounce
his name I wish I could I'm horrible at
pronouncing things but it kind of looks
familiar right like you've seen this
pose before except not on Law & Order
SVU and that's because it is a physical
representation of Napoleon the first at
his coronation painted by angrist so you
can see here the artist Wylie took
inspiration and we're still like dealing
with depth and dealing with these
patterns and we haven't understand
inherent cultural understanding of these
patterns like you understand that I see
is pronouncing that he is the king but
in the same way that IKEA is copying
Napoleon Napoleon is copying god this is
yawns onyx Ghent Altarpiece God the
Father it's a panel within an altarpiece
with multiple panels and you can see the
similarities between God the Father and
Napoleon and we continue to use these
similar patterns in CSS with the
prevalence of hamburger menus and these
representations that we all understand
and have a user experience that is
cohesive and everyone across the board
gets that and so I think that as a
community we should always be aware of
those choices that are being made and
what that means for the future
generations of web development and the
things that we're passing along but you
know you don't need to go to school and
get a masters degree to be an artist
anybody can be an artist anybody can
create things just like you can create
anything out of CSS with your code and I
think that looking at the artists of
today is going to help us figure out
what the future of CSS looks like
after the neoclassical period which was
what we just saw with Napoleon we had
the advent of photography and
photography meant that we no longer
needed paintings to represent real life
because with photographs we could
document real life much quicker albeit
slightly expensive but not nearly as
expensive as hiring an artist to paint
something for you at the same time
psychology was being developed and
people were being encouraged to explore
their feelings and emotions so during
this period that's when we had the birth
of abstract art and now we're looking at
not the figure within but the figure on
the canvas as a surface is just as
important to look at in terms of art as
the canvas as a window and here we have
a piece by Chuck Close it's a portrait
of Kara Walker who's also a famous
artist who I adore and what's
interesting is that Chuck Close
abstracts the portrait by painting
individual water colors just like pixels
and therefore turning our focus away
from the photograph as a whole and the
image the figure of Kara Walker as a
whole and instead we have a chance to
focus on what is on the canvas and the
texture and the color and the
abstraction and I think that we are
going to see more and more of this in
the future with CSS as we become more
aware of the screen as a surface as
opposed to a window little side trivia
about Chuck Close he has bear with me
while I process Pro so prosopagnosia
which is face blindness so when he
paints these portraits he will look at
the photo and look back at the painting
and go back and forth and he actually
like doesn't recognize the person while
he's doing these paintings which is why
like what people have theorized is why
his painting seems so photographic
because he is so able to
separate himself from the person who
he's painting and he just sees the
elements of what he's working with and
in the same way that we work with pixels
and now we're working with like CSS grid
and stuff we can look at this piece and
notice how it's being abstracted into
something that is completely different
from the way we used to handle art and
it ran across this very interesting
piece that Ivana showed me earlier today
using typography portrait by Carolyn
Portugal she uses typography and SVG
animation to deconstruct and subvert the
meaning of the text so just like check
closes subverting the meaning of the
portrait we can subvert the meaning of
the text that we're given to display on
a website to provide information and we
can provide information of our own
making
even more deeply abstracted we can look
at Mark Rothko's paintings of color and
when we look at these what you don't
know is that there's tiny thin layers of
color across the whole canvas Mark
Rothko would paint very very thin layers
over and over and over to develop this
glowing Lumosity something that I akin a
lot to the fact that our screens are
actually light glowing from behind and
so I like to look at Rothko and consider
the fact that when we're creating
something with CSS oftentimes color and
light have a lot to do with the
expression and the emotion that is
caused by what you're looking at on your
screen in 1816 Schopenhauer wrote on
vision and color which explained his
theory of the physiological rate of
intensity of color saturation and he
developed a spectrum of color that he
deemed high too low too high too low
intensity with black on one end of the
spectrum moving into violet blue and
green green and red being the center the
highest contrasting moving down into
orange yellow and white and you can see
here there's no green there's no red
this is a very subdued painting with
notes of violet and notes of blue and we
have a kind of calming sense when we
look at this painting the colors
communicate to us a sense of peace but
when you look at something like orange
and yellow it drives up your heartrate
it gets you excited it is full of
intensity and in the same way that you
can abstract down a painting into color
to express emotion you can do so with
CSS in the screen and color we can't
always look at color as it really is
sometimes it's determined by the context
and here light and color help to define
space but here we have the absence of
color the absence of saturation helps us
to define space so this is a piece of
optical art by Bridget Riley she was
basically the front runner of this art
motif and she was also the first woman
to win an International Prize in
painting at the Venice Biennial in 1968
and what she's creating here is she's
expressing movement by manipulating the
surface and depth with the contour and
saturation this is something that we
could execute ourselves with code by
manipulating a line by manipulating its
curvature and it creates a wonderful
sense of tension and sense of movement
across the page even though it's static
there's no movement in it but as you
look at it it begins to kind of wave
back and forth
and to give you a sense of how we can
utilize these abstractions through code
this is a project that my friend Ainsley
Wagner worked on where she took sound
and used it to manipulate an abstract
representation with colors and light and
they just this wonderful performance
piece that I love so this is making art
with code this is like the most abstract
that you can get and as we move towards
pure expression and away from our
dependency on text and our dependency on
like newspapers derivative layouts with
columns and rows of text I hope that you
all are a little inspired to go out and
make something fun and interesting thing
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]